[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo venute oggi a raccontare la nostra
storia che poi è la storia di molti
amarsi mettere su famiglia crescere dei
figli quando avevo 5 anni già sapevo che
avrei avuto dei bambini come molti qui
immagino quindi quando a 29 mi sono
fidanzata con francesca effettivamente
abbiamo dovuto cominciare a ragionare su
questa questione perché c'erano delle
complicazioni
io ero stato in passato con degli uomini
in particolare con uno molto a lungo ma
quando ho incontrato lei che ho capito
che questo era il mio posto nel mondo
era la mia metà della mela era con
l'eroe migliore però ho capito anche
un'altra cosa ho capito che rinunciava
un privilegio da quel momento non
sarebbe più stata solamente io maria
silvia diventavo gli occhi del mondo una
lesbica
io ero esattamente la stessa persona di
prima stessi difetti stessi pregi e io e
lei facevamo quello che fanno tutti
andavamo al cinema
mangiavamo fuori la pizza poi cominciamo
la nostra vita professionale arrivavamo
la nostra casa
ma adesso c'era qualcuno che pensava di
sapere di più su di noi sui nostri
desideri sulle nostre possibilità
ecco questo è il pregiudizio quel foglio
bianco che sono le nostre giovani vite e
su cui ognuno di noi da scrivere la sua
storia delle scritte pre stampate a
caratteri cubitali queste scritte
parlano di te e tu non ti riconosci e ho
capito che non succedeva solo a me
succede va a tutte le persone che
appartenevano alla minoranza questo
pregiudizio sulle per scrive grava sulle
persone omosessuali 17 anni fa in italia
quando abbiamo cominciato a fare la
nostra famiglia non esisteva perché
ancora non si conosce non si conoscevano
le famiglie omogenitoriali genitori
omosessuali con dei bambini
questo pregiudizio si è creato
lentamente soprattutto dopo la
discussione sulle unioni civili
attraverso i media e il parlamento
adesso oggi ognuno si permette di dire
se un omosessuale può essere genitore
oppure no
ma proviamo a immaginarci una
discussione pubblica sul fatto se una
categoria di persone che so i biondi
bruni gli operai i rom i neri o gli
ebrei possano meno fare dei figli
ovviamente nessuno ha il diritto di
decidere se un essere umano può o meno
mettere al mondo un bambino invece c'è
chi dice si dice contrario alla
genitorialità omosessuale e la prima
argomentazione che due persone dello
stesso sesso non possono fisicamente
concepire un figlio ma concepire un
figlio non è soltanto un atto fisico è
prima di tutto un atto di volontà
una presa di responsabilità e lo vediamo
anche proprio nel verbo concepire come
lo usiamo tutti i giorni concepire una
realtà a concepire un'idea si concepisce
nella propria testa il solo legame
biologico non ci non può renderci
genitori
e infatti se noi abbiamo un legame
biologico con qualcuno senza saperlo noi
non percepiamo questo legame abbiamo
bisogno di
viverlo nella testa per poterlo sentire
come reale
dunque il legame biologico non è
sufficiente ma sappiamo che non è
neanche necessario
proviamo a immaginarci di eliminare da
questa platea tutti i figli adottivi
tutti i figli nati con la procreazione
assistita che non hanno un legame
biologico con il proprio padre
facciamo un test del dna quante persone
sparirebbero da questa sala per me e
mary è stato facile istintivo e
irresistibile concepire un figlio nella
nostra testa e immaginarci come una
famiglia con dei bambini e dunque siamo
andate naturalmente verso un percorso di
procreazione assistita come qualsiasi
altra coppia con delle viti fertilità le
persone omosessuali non sono persone e
sterili non lo sono mai state sacco era
madre oscar wilde era padre e quello che
vivono adesso delle coppie omosessuali
che mettono al mondo dei bambini come
abbiamo visto non è così una grande
novità
quante famiglie non hanno rapporti
genetici fra genitori e figli in quante
famiglie non esiste una madre e un padre
e una e una sola madre e padre
quante sono le famiglie che si rivolgono
alla medicina per procurare per
procreare e infine quante sono le
famiglie che portano il peso di un
pregiudizio
sì perché poi è proprio questo il
pregiudizio che non ci vuole genitori è
proprio la cosa più pesante da vivere
per le nostre famiglie per i nostri
bambini ma non è certamente una ragione
per non esistere se un bambino a scuola
viene preso in giro perché porta gli
occhiali
il problema non sono certamente gli
occhiali e quella classe bisogna capire
perché bisogna educare nello stesso modo
bisogna insegnare ma veramente insegnare
che gay non è una parolaccia
ai ragazzi è insegnare alla società
tutta che essere omosessuali è una delle
varianti dell'identità umana come essere
biondi bruni o portare gli occhiali ma
eccoci alla fine del secolo scorso a
parigi che già ci sentiamo una famiglia
che già siamo una famiglia
non abbiamo ancora dei figli ma già
stiamo pensando a come proteggere questi
bambini che ancora
sono nati la geografia è molto
importante nella nostra storia ci siamo
dovute muovere su una mappa molto più
ampia di quella italiana
abbiamo dovuto attraversare confini
geografici abbiamo dovuto attraversare i
confini linguistici
abbiamo dovuto attraversare i confini
culturali siamo stati emigranti nel
senso più profondo del termine
e ancora il nostro paese l'italia non
godiamo di piena cittadinanza legale
ma torniamo indietro eravamo a parigi
gli ero lì con una borsa della comunità
europea nel 95 e guardandomi intorno
capivo che un posto al mondo per noi
c'era
e allora abbiamo iniziato a studiare la
situazione anzi veramente a studiare a
leggere a confrontarci e imparare a
parlare con gli altri a ragionare per
molti anni 67 anni ma da subito è stata
chiara una cosa non si trattava di
crescere insieme il figlio suo mio come
una coppia di amiche o diamanti no
si trattava di mettere al mondo un
figlio insieme un bambino che mai
sarebbe nato senza il nostro incontro
senza il nostro amore figlio di entrambe
perché noi due avremmo avuto da allora
per sempre la responsabilità della sua
esistenza come poi succede a tutti i
genitori quando mettono al mondo dei
bambini ma mettere al mondo dei bambini
non significa sono volersi bene
costruire una famiglia significa anche
scritture significa leggi infatti
altrimenti una festa era bollito di
famiglia significa dare inizio a una
storia si affronteranno dei cambiamenti
delle difficoltà delle paure dei
pericoli significa assumersi delle
enormi responsabilità anche nei
confronti delle figlie l'origine e
significa presentarsi agli altri andare
verso la società con la scuola con la
vita di quartiere è proprio questo
presentarsi agli altri cioè portare i
nostri figli nel mondo e raccontarci
alla società in cui viviamo è stata la
nostra battaglia quotidiana che è
cominciata ancora
all'asilo nido anzi direi prima quando
al primo colloquio col ginecologo ed è
andata avanti e continua fino al
parlamento ma torniamo al momento
indietro al 1995 noi eravamo a parigi e
abbiamo però deciso di tornare in italia
perché comunque non volevamo vivere la
nostra storia in esilio volevamo vivere
nella città dove eravamo cresciute e
vicino alle nostre famiglie d'origine e
dunque come una frase che avevo scritto
sul diario quando andavo a scuola
abbiamo cercato di essere noi il
cambiamento che volevamo nel mondo
quindi torniamo in italia ma in
orizzonti rimangono sempre molto più
ampi
abbiamo cercato imparato altrove la
nostra libertà e ci siamo anche molto
divertite a a new york
abbiamo comprato il primo libro per i
nostri bambini che non erano ancora nati
e si intitolava eder a due mamme a
leiden in olanda
abbiamo fatto il nostro primo colloquio
e le nostre prime inseminazioni ed è un
luogo che rimarrà per noi per sempre un
luogo magico approvi in stan degli stati
uniti
abbiamo fatto delle vacanze con
centinaia di famiglie omosessuali e i
loro figli e alcuni di questi genitori
erano già nonni in olanda in belgio in
danimarca qui siamo in danimarca dove
abbiamo fatto le inseminazioni siamo poi
tornate con i nostri figli a mostrare
loro i luoghi e le cliniche del loro
concepimento e poi finalmente in spagna
abbiamo potuto sposarci a quel punto
avevamo già i nostri quattro bambini a
fare da pagetti al nostro matrimonio e
tutti i parenti e gli amici che sono
venuti a festeggiar ci abbiamo vissuto
cose bellissime e molto emozionanti
anche spaventosi e difficili
siamo una famiglia come tante numerosa
con quattro figlie con un quotidiano
molto faticoso e da realtà il quotidiano
ha preso il possesso improvvisamente
delle nostre vite quando 18 anni fa
quando siamo arrivati al corso pre parto
con la nostra prima bambina nella pancia
e a quel punto non interessare più a
nessuno che fossimo due mamme perché
eravamo tutti in panicate con questa
idea di dover partorire e poi bambini
sarebbero stati sani e poi avrebbero
dormito e poi quando sono nati la
tenerezza indicibile di queste vanin e
katie stringevano e avevano solo te su
cui contare e poi decidere la materna
fare i turni in ospedale perché gemelli
a valle polmoniti fare la spesa a
decidere cosa mangiare e poi studiano
anno studia nelle attività pomeridiane
chi li accompagna e poi le gelosie fra
fratelli le litigate e far quadrare i
conti del menage familiare e poi tre
mesi d'estate quando le squadre chiudono
e bisogna organizzare bambini perché
comunque le donne lavorano in italia è
così
e insomma problemi problemi un sacco di
divertimento ma anche tanti problemi non
parliamo poi del cellulare quando glielo
compri e come fai a farli smettere a
giocare ai suoi giochi elettronici e
come fai a mandarli a dormire e alla
fine questa casa non è un albergo
[Applauso]
ma la nostra famiglia una famiglia come
tutte le altre questa è un'evidenza e e
quel e quel nemico invisibile il
pregiudizio quella strega che incombeva
sulle culle dei nostri bambini come
dalla favola della bella addormentata
nel bosco a quello abbiamo dovuto
pensare ci dobbiamo pensare sempre
perché arriva all'improvviso e può avere
il volto delle persone più care delle
persone più impensabili e più vicine ma
la cosa più grave è che viene alimentato
da voci pubbliche voce che dovrebbero
difenderci da amministratori da politici
che costruiscono su questo il proprio
consenso e la propria fortuna e le
nostre vite diventano la benzina del
loro successo
si è infatti lentamente mentre i cuori
delle persone che avevamo vicino
crescevano insieme a noi si aprivano la
nostra situazione
alcuni politici hanno fatto proprio il
percorso inverso
abbiamo subito anche attacchi feroci si
è reso necessario per noi rispondere a
questi attacchi e per i nostri figli non
potevamo stare zitte
anche se poi sia delle persone un po
timide però comunque abbiamo dovuto
farlo lo stesso siamo diventate quello
che si dice delle attiviste per i
diritti civili nel 2005 con altri
genitori abbiamo fondato un'associazione
che si chiama famiglia arcobaleno ed
allora molto attiva nel campo dei
diritti civili eravamo una manciata di
persone adesso ci sono migliaia di
iscritti e abbiamo creato anche una casa
editrice di libri per bambini
nata per rispondere alla domanda dei
compagni di classe perché ai due mamme
fatta i nostri figli non c'era una
risposta nella letteratura per
l'infanzia a questa domanda e quindi
abbiamo cercato di darla a noi è un
libro è sempre la risposta migliore
i nostri figli avevano bisogno di
rispecchiarsi nei libri
loro e noi avevamo bisogno di uno
strumento per raccontare la nostra
famiglia ai loro compagni di classe
anche ai loro genitori
c'è stato qualcuno che ha creduto
fortemente nel nostro progetto
editoriale che racconta ai bambini
l'omosessualità semplicemente come una
delle tante varianti dell'amore
quell'amore da cui nascono le famiglie e
alta nel grande disegnatore altan ha
illustrato il nostro libro più noto
piccolo uovo che semplicemente
descrivere tanti tipi di famiglie come
tutti tutte come un posto bello in cui
crescere famiglia con due mamme con due
papà ma anche famiglia adottiva con un
solo genitore famiglia con mamma papà e
bambini la presentazione di questo libro
fa nessun agente tanti numero
rappresentata nel un libro per bambini
la famiglia in un modo in cui ci fosse
posto per tutti ed è diventato un po il
simbolo di un discorso ai più piccoli
basata sull'inclusione e sulla
valorizzazione delle differenze al punto
da essere portato in piazza quando
alcune organizzazioni di estrema destra
lo hanno attaccato e hanno parlato di
volerlo bruciare la casa editrice
l'associazione sono delle realtà che
sono andate molto al di là di quello che
pensavamo di fare all'inizio quando
abbiamo deciso di vivere la nostra vita
ma a volte per ottenere le cose più
semplici bisogna fare moltissima strada
e noi questa è la strada che abbiamo
dovuto fare per riuscire a essere una
famiglia persa tra le tante altre
persone questa strada la devono fare
materialmente magari per mare c'è chi
deve attraversare dei limiti fisici che
c'è chi deve attraversare le proprie
paure per designare le persone
omosessuali transessuali lesbiche
transgender si utilizza un acronimo lgbt
che occorra altre lettere
in più che indicano varie altre
minoranze noi pensiamo che è molto
importante aggiungere a questo acronimo
la lettera e di eterosessuali
perché tutti a un certo punto ci
ritroviamo ad essere minoranze tutti a
un certo punto ci sentiamo inadeguati e
soprattutto a un certo punto può
succedere che ci troviamo spalle al muro
inchiodati dallo sguardo o dalla
violenza degli altri per questo
riteniamo che le battaglie del movimento
lgbt riguardino tutti e tutte anche gli
eterosessuali e alla fine la nostra
storia è davvero un po la storia di
tutti avevamo un sogno e abbiamo cercato
di raggiungerlo nessuno nasce con un
destino segnato anche se a volte ti
fanno sentire di avere le carte
sbagliate le carte da perdente ma in
verità a guardare da vicino proprio
nessuno ha le carte in regola e alla
fine cosa ci ha insegnato alla nostra
storia ci ha insegnato che la vera
libertà non è fare quello che si vuole
nascosti nelle proprie case senza essere
nominati da nessuno e circondati dal
silenzio o no la vera libertà è essere
se stessi alla luce del sole ed essere
chiamati per nome
a volte più difficile a volte più facile
ma questo vale per tutti voi anche
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]